let's simplify things a little bit okay
here's our situation we've got and i'm
just looking at it so i don't know i'm
just interested in the forces so i don't
need the whole 3d picture
okay as we already know your gravity
that's fine
okay and you have the normal force
and in our ideal world situation we
imagined what would happen if those all
exactly cancelled out okay if you were
traveling at the perfect speed
and the angle angle was exactly
right okay but as you see these things
can all change
now let's just have an example and we've
looked at these before right
if i'm going faster than the optimum
speed
if i'm going faster than the optimum
speed what's happening right
well that additional speed it's pushing
me out
further right the centripetal force is
not enough to try and compensate and
that's why it's going further and
further away
okay so therefore what you're going to
experience
is a force in now you're in the car
right and you've played corners before
you're going faster and faster you take
the corner which way
are people inside the car being flown
which way
the outside of the turn right because
guess what
you passenger you have inertia as well
and just like the uh
just like the car before you want to go
off in a tangent and that's
out of the circle okay so you've got
what we call
a lateral force okay lateral just means
sideways
you would think oh sideways that means
horizontal uh but we don't want to use
that word right because horizontal here
means that way
so you've got a lateral force upwards
away from the ground i guess but
you can imagine the reverse situation if
you take this and you know
you know grandpa's driving or something
like that and i'm like no i don't want
to
go so fast okay so the opposite will
happen okay
you're going to have a lateral force but
it's going to be downward
okay now just like
in other situations where you go up and
down you can define whichever you want
as
positive and negative so long as you're
consistent and you say what you're doing
okay but the point is that we've got
this new axis involved here and it's
perpendicular to the um
should have labeled perpendicular to the
normal force it's along the road
okay that's that's the lateral force you
experience
so let's have a look at this example
i've given you a road
radius don't worry about the mass of the
car we don't know what it is
let's have gravity 9.8 and the road
designer has
designed the curve so the optimum
velocity you're meant to take so this is
obviously a highway road is 120
kilometers per hour
right so here are our questions number
one
if 120 kilometers per hour is the
optimum speed how how far
should i make the embankment right and
then
secondly what happens at these speeds
what happens if someone comes around
and ignores the speed limit and um goes
180 kilometers per hour around the
corner instead
what lateral force will they be
experiencing which way and how much
and then likewise the grandpa comes
along and wants to go
slower which way will he experience a
force and how much
okay so let's have a look at this
first thing you've got to do is um all
of these units all of these units
not in them they're not in si they're
not in meters
or in seconds right so therefore i'm
going to start off by saying okay here's
um
he's part a r r that radius i want that
in
meters don't i sir r equals a thousand
okay um i also want the velocity in
meters per second
right so the velocity is well how many
meters in 120
kilometers 120 000.
and then it's over how many seconds in
an hour and the answer is
3600. that's meters
and that's seconds okay i think it works
out to is it 50.
no it's another awkward number 100 on
click
that's right that's i'm thinking of
puppet okay
so now i've worked out those in the
right units okay go back to what we
looked at in the ideal world
because that's what this is talking
about the ideal theta
okay tan theta no hold on
other way around v squared
v squared is equal to i think we said
was it r r g ten theta is that what
you've got
r g tan theta right
so theta's what i'm trying to find i'll
just sum everything in you've got
a hundred on three squared that's a
thousand that's nine point eight
yeah rearrange a little bit what's a
hundred square
ten thousand right
ten thousand so you'll have ten left
three times nine point eight would back
your calculator what do you get for
theta let's do nearest minute
nearest minute
see anyone got it what have i got
where what oh yes sorry is that
square with the right numbers in it
someone gotta do 10 invest what do you
get
i'm expecting a pretty small angle cool
yeah i found something right
okay so far so good so this is our ideal
world we've got the right speed
okay and we've decided what the angle of
the road is so now
this is true for the rest of the
question okay so we can take that right
now let's have a look at part b part b
and we've got this guy coming around at
180 kilometers per hour
right so that's going to be 180 000
on 3600 meters per second and i think
this is this is the 50 that i was
thinking
times five yeah i think it works out
okay
so what happens at this point okay being
that things are not going to balance out
nice and neatly anymore
we're gonna get something like this okay
so i want to account for this lateral
force
right so which way would you like to
define
as positive which way do you want do you
want it to be up or do you want me down
up okay sure so let's make that
okay so now what i'm going to do is i'm
going to draw myself a new diagram okay
so like that one but with all of these
numbers on it okay so
let's see here i'm going to go over here
okay now there's the normal force right
but i'm not going to worry about that
too much what i'm really interested is
the lateral force because i've already
worked out all the bits though
the n cos theta and the ensign theta for
the normal force that's okay
right so if i have the lateral force
going up in this direction okay now when
i want to resolve it
i'm going to horizontal and vertical
part so get your horizontal
here
and you've got a lateral vertical pump
here okay so use your geometry
you have your feeder there which we
already know six degrees 28 minutes
corresponding angles so i see there's a
feeder there
and a theta there okay so what do you
work out your
horizontal part of the component to be
horizontal component
that's adjacent right it's adjacent so i
think you're going to get
l cos theta there going in that
direction
conversely you have l sine theta going
upwards
okay
now you already worked out before what
your um normal forces will be i think
you've got
n cos theta going that way and and sine
theta going this way so now when i
resolve everything
vertically
what's going on vertically what's going
on
you've got the lateral force going
upwards and you have the normal force
also going upwards right
so i think we're going to get l sine
theta
plus n cos theta
is that right yeah and that should be
counteracting
gravity yep let's call that one
horizontally what's happening
now these forces are acting in opposite
directions right so i've got
l cos theta going in the positive
direction
now hold on a second we define l cos
theta going positive this way right
but in our normal situation right
horizontally
i think of the force toward the center
as positive right so this would be
negative wouldn't it it's going away
from where the normal is going okay so
that means i'm going to put i'll put the
normal first maybe i should have done
that over here
minus l cos theta
right whichever way they're going
they're going in opposite directions
okay so that's mv squared on
okay now what are we trying to work out
i'm trying to find out what's the
lateral force
how much is it and which direction is it
facing so in other words
you're solving for l okay and you've got
these two equations to use
i want you to have a think about this
for a second i'll let you have a go take
a couple minutes
what are you going to do to equations
one and two so that you can solve for l
remember m is a constant so you don't
need to worry about it we know what g
is we know what v is or rather
that's what v is in this case and we
know what the radius is okay
so how are you going to get all of the
other stuff the n's and the thetas
out of the picture and just have l
the problem we are encountering is that
one and two are hard to put together
right but it's not so bad i mean when
you see something like this for instance
awkward number four x
okay yeah all right well if i'm going to
put these two equations together
i'm going to need to eliminate something
right and the way you would do it here
is well for instance
suppose you wanted to eliminate y okay
if i want to eliminate why what i'll do
is i'll take this whole thing and i'll
multiply it by two
and then i'll take this whole thing and
then i'll multiply it by five
then i'll have a minus ten y here a plus
ten right here i'll add them and then
poof it's gone
okay that's that's not so hard okay you
have exactly
exactly the same scenario here it's just
that instead of numbers
you've got fluffy letters and greek
stuff okay but that's all right
it works in exactly the same way watch
let's take equation one right what i
want to get rid of
is the n cos theta okay and i see
there's a and sine theta here so i don't
need to multiply by n
that's common but if i multiply this one
by sine and this one by cos then they'll
be
the same just like these would be the
same and then i can subtract
okay so i'll take equation one and i'll
multiply that one by a sine
and then i'll take away equation two
multiplied
by cos okay if i do that watch what
happens right well
you'll get l sine squared there
right you'll have an n sine theta cos
theta
subtracting an n sine theta cos theta so
they're just going to go
okay and there's minus and then that's a
negative so double negative so i'll have
plus
l cos squared theta oh how convenient
okay
so that's good that's good what am i
going to have over here
well i multiplied things so that makes
it a little bit messy but that's okay
you're going to get what mg sine theta
minus mv squared on r
cos theta is that all right happy with
that
okay let's just tidy up a little bit
sine squared plus cos squared that just
gives you 1.
i'll just take out m i mean it doesn't
make it a huge amount
liter but you are going to have m in the
final equation because it's just a
constant right so you have nothing to
evaluate
m sine theta sorry g sine theta
v squared on r cos theta okay
cool now the good thing about this
equation here maybe it's worth putting a
box around right
is that it's irrespective of v so i can
take my two values of v and then just
put them into the same equation
and then i can get a value for l okay so
in the case of part one what i would do
is i say
l equals m it's just going to stay there
9.8 sine what was theta again
like six degrees right twenty points
minus okay this time i decided that v
was
fifty
um r is a thousand right
and you got cos the same angle
okay now once you get at the end let's
just round it off a little bit
you get minus 1.38
m i think okay now
m is going to be positive right it's a
mass so then what does this mean
which way is this force facing and you
have a look
and it's it's going downward okay why is
that
why is l going downward we said if you
go faster
you get pushed outwards right
ha now inertia is pushing out that way
but this force this force is actually
friction this is what we started with
this is the thing that's keeping you if
there was no bank
right if i was just going around right
then friction is what keeps your wheels
on the ground remember that situation
we're looking at before
it was optimum speed it was perfect
everything balanced out
but if everything does not balance out
then you're going to have friction
quite a lot of it okay depending on the
mass of your car right
now just a quick note this friction is
acting in that way
and the faster i go the more friction
will be acting that way which is why if
you've ever
been driving along on a highway or
something and you're looking at the road
and on the road in front of you
you can see there are tire marks right
these kinds of things what does that
mean where did they come from
okay well intuition tells you someone
took this corner and they took it
too fast right the faster you take it
the more friction there will be
and friction as you know it's a force it
causes energy
it's hot right so it burns off part of
the tires and that's where they are
right because they took the corner at a
speed that was higher than the optimum
okay so the friction is acting downwards
otherwise it'll just
fly off okay now if we
replay this situation okay and all we
have to do to get a new speed is well
this is half
it's exactly half so all i have to do is
adjust this number
that's convenient when you do that
what do you get 0.52 or something
okay so as you'd expect this time
friction is still doing its job
but what it's doing is it's acting
upward it's stopping your car
from sliding down the hill because
you're going too slow hurry up okay but
you see what's going on right too slow
friction's got to act up
if you think about it this way if you
just stopped on the hill
right just motionless okay friction is
acting on you
otherwise you're going to slide down the
heel if there's not enough friction oh
you just roll down just like my keys
rolled off
the diary okay but if you're going it
won't be so bad but there will still be
some friction
keeping you up in that direction
otherwise you'll slide down the hill
okay